hi my name is Kyle Steckler and I'm a
machine learning engineer on the
advanced Solutions lab team at Google
cloud in this talk we're going to dive
into an introduction to image generation
specifically I'll provide an
introduction to diffusion models a
family of models that have recently
shown tremendous promise in the image
generation space
with that said image generation has long
been a field of interest and there are
many interesting approaches that you may
have heard about
now while many approaches have been
implemented for image generation some of
the more promising ones over time have
been model families such as variational
autoencoders which encode images to a
compressed size and then decode back to
the original size while learning the
distribution of the data itself
generative adversarial models or Gans
have also been quite popular these
models are really interesting they
actually pit two neural networks against
each other one neural network the
generator creates images and the other
neural network the discriminator
predicts if the image is real or fake
over time the discriminator gets better
and better at distinguishing between
real and fake and the generator gets
better and better at creating real
looking fakes you may have heard the
term deep fakes before
uh and lastly Auto regressive models
these things generate images by treating
an image as a sequence of pixels and the
modern approach with auto regressive
models actually draws much of its
inspiration from how llms or large
language models handle text very
interesting
now in this talk this is really going to
be the focus and this is one of the
newer image generation model families
and that is diffusion models
diffusion models draw their inspiration
from physics specifically thermodynamics
and while they were first really
introduced for image generation in 2015
it took a few years for the idea to
really take off
within the last few years though 2020 up
until now we have seen a massive
increase of diffusion models in both the
research space and now today in the
industry space as well diffusion models
underpin many of the state-of-the-art
image generation systems that you may be
familiar with today
diffusion models show promise across a
number of different use cases
unconditioned diffusion models where
models have no additional input or
instruction can be trained from images
of a specific thing such as faces as you
can see on the slide here and it will
learn to generate new images of that
thing
another example of unconditioned
generation is super resolution which is
really powerful in enhancing low quality
images
we also have conditioned generation
models and these give us things like
text to image where we can generate an
image from a text prompt and other
things like image in painting and text
guided image to image where we can
remove or add things we can edit the
image itself
now let's take a little bit of a deeper
dive into diffusion models and talk
about how do these things actually work
it's noted on the slide here the
essential idea is to systematically and
slowly destroy structure in a data
distribution through an iterative
forward diffusion process
really this is going to be adding noise
iteratively to an image
we then learn a reverse diffusion
process that restores structure in the
data yielding a highly flexible and
tractable generative model of the data
in other words we can add noise to an
image iteratively and we can then train
a model that learns how to denoise an
image thus generating novel images
so the goal here is that we want to have
this model learned to denoise to remove
noise
and in that aspect then we could start
here on on the left of the slide we
could start from Pure Noise
and from that Pure Noise we could have a
model that will be able to synthesize a
novel image
now I know that there's a bit of math
notation on this slide so let's break it
down just a little bit
we start with a large data set of images
but let's just take a single image here
shown on the right hand side well we can
start this forward diffusion process and
we can go from x0 the initial image to
X1 the initial image with a little bit
of noise added to it and we can do this
over and over again iteratively adding
more and more noise to the initial image
now this distribution we call Q and it
only depends on the previous step so if
we do this over and over iteratively
adding more noise we need to think about
how many times do we perform that
operation and the initial research paper
did this 1000 times
so ideally with that number being high
enough 1000 by the end of it we should
reach a state of Pure Noise
and so by this point
all structure in the initial image is
completely gone we're just looking at
Pure Noise now obviously that's kind of
the easy part it's not too difficult to
perform Q to iteratively add more and
more noise the challenging part is how
do we go from a noisy image to a
slightly less noisy image
and so this will refer to as the reverse
diffusion process and at this stage
every step of the way every step that we
add noise we also learn the reverse
diffusion process
that is we train a machine learning
model that takes in as input the noisy
image and predicts the noise that's been
added to it
now let's look at that from a slightly
different angle
we can visualize a single training step
of the model here
so we have our initial image X on the
left and we sample at a time step to
create a noisy image
we then send that through our denoising
model
with the goal of predicting the noise so
the output of the model is the predicted
noise
but we just added the noise to this
image we know what it is so we can
actually compare that we can see what is
the difference between the model's
predicted noise and the actual noise
that we added
now this model is trained similar to
most machine learning models that you
might be familiar with to minimize that
difference and over time after seeing
enough examples this model gets very
very good at removing noise from images
and now for the fun part this is where
it gets really cool is we need to think
about once we train this model how do we
generate images with it well it's
actually fairly intuitive we can just
start with pure absolute noise and send
that noise through our model that is
trained
we then take the output the predicted
noise and subtract it from the initial
noise and if we do that over and over
and over again we end up with a
generated image
another way to think about this is that
the model is able to learn the real data
distribution of images that it's seen
and then sample from that learn
distribution to create new novel images
very cool
as I'm sure we're all aware there have
been many advances in this space in just
the last few years
and while many of the exciting new
technologies on vertex AI for image
generation are underpinned with
diffusion models lots of work has been
done to generate images faster and with
more control hopefully now after taking
a little bit of a look under the covers
into how diffusion models work you have
a bit better intuition as to what's
actually going on with these really new
Innovative model types
we've also seen wonderful results
combining the power of diffusion models
with the power of llms or large language
models for that can really enable us to
create context aware photorealistic
images from a text prompt
one great example of this is Imogen from
Google research while it's a bit more
complicated than what we've talked
through in this session you can see that
at its core it's a composition of an llm
and a few diffusion-based models this is
a really exciting space and I'm thrilled
to see this wonderful technology make
its way into Enterprise grade products
on vertex AI thanks for listening